countdown mother pucker high four three
two one liftoff welcome to another
episode of genius brain if it's uploaded
today it must be a Thursday because
every Thursday is just me and David I'm
your other host Jochen Sakawa and that
is my other host David slow here we go
today we're gonna do some patreon
exclusive questions what is it called
genius support suggestions genius
suggestions I like support too you know
I support sounds good yeah I was like
you know like a good good brah we
support we support them to it as well
we'll call it genius brah genius bro we
we give good support we give good we
lift them up you know what I mean we
lift you up yeah genius brah that might
be better is genius brah why we lift you
up and support you is brah that's [ __ ]
dope but this is we're exclusive patreon
owners can give us questions and write
you know whatever they feel whatever
they think and then you know we pick out
the best out of the bunch mm-hmm and we
go off the more descripted the better
because you know the better advice that
we can give we'll go on Tanja's but
we'll try to give you some good genius
brah suggestions lift you up and support
you [ __ ] yeah all right so here's the
first one that we got today man this is
from Wonder brain the gap of being funny
versus doing stand-up comedy I'm always
cracking jokes and love making people
laugh and have been concerning doing
minor stand-up but I don't know what my
understand you may be just testing the
waters yeah either do stand-up but you
know minor stand-up like if you up there
and you're doing stand-up you don't that
may be for a small crowd at a bar
nothing major you know just a minor one
yeah
maybe at the senior citizen a church
retreat
oh nothing major just minor Church stand
up the best in but from what I hear and
what I research being the funniness of
being the funniest one in the group
doesn't translate to being what funny
for standup
well first of all you can't speak
English
or right very well let's work on that
when you write your stand-up check your
typos with both you and Joe's experience
what is that gap also if you are trying
to stand on the first time how do you
prepare to do just a 10 minute set and
not bomb what works best and what
doesn't work
man this is actually a very loaded
question so what a lot of people don't
know is I've been doing stand-up since I
was [ __ ] 16 years old [ __ ] do
you think comedy clubs at that young
yeah I had a [ __ ] fake ID Dan I was
this size at 16 also they didn't they
didn't check check please let me in and
plus like the homies new homies and then
I was allowed to go in Wow and so I've
been doing stand-up since I was 16 and I
but the very first stand-up thing I ever
did was at a community church event that
was open to the public and I did my
first stand-up set there that's a minor
stand-up mess and I understand that
there was only children definitely
minors there so you know it's
interesting because you are a hundred
percent right just because you're funny
in front of your friends doesn't mean
that you can do stand-up and what I mean
by that is that stand-up is a [ __ ]
skill it is performance art it is public
speaking and it's and it's it's all that
just wrapped up into one package it is
something that's very very difficult
there are extent of comics right now
that a lot of people think that they
can't do stand-up because they're funny
they can't do it because they don't know
how to write a story they don't know how
to tell story they don't know how to do
a setup they don't know how to break
comedy down they have terrible timing
and it's it's it's something that has to
be very much developed I use a great
example when I was doing stand-up for
the first time there was a homie of ours
[ __ ] funny funny is dude in our group
dude every time he opened his [ __ ]
mouth I would die laughing so he wanted
to go to this comedy spot in downtown
Sacramento or Old Town Sacramento and uh
he decided to do a set this [ __ ]
I've never seen somebody bomb and burned
so bad really [ __ ] line it even
prepped for it and wrote a thing or he
just decided to stand up and start going
well he made a big mistake in thinking
that he was telling a lot of inside
jokes that we as his friends would know
because we are all and he kind of
expected people to know those jokes even
though they've never met him they were
no background to it he was a joker he
was the Joker and so he tried doing
stand-up a couple more times and I do
believe that this guy's way funnier than
I am mm-hmm but he just couldn't do well
in stand-up and at that time I was I was
doing stand-up and I was doing pretty
well I'm making a decent name for myself
and it wasn't because I was I'm like
super funny it's just that I would sit
there and I would have to look back and
study how to set up these jokes how it
would work why it doesn't work sometimes
too when you do Stan you'll find out
that sometimes it's not your joke it's
the way that you delivered it mmm you're
not giving people time enough to breathe
there's a lot to it man yeah do this
hard dude I mean I I never legit did
stand-up in that way I mean I've always
did to me it's like onstage improv is
what I call it back and forth with Bart
I do speeches but I don't think I legit
consider myself as a stand-up comedian
cuz I might give funny speeches but I
never did sets in a comedy club by
myself did the grind did the traditional
stand-up thing so I can't really answer
this but what I do see the connection is
like this always happens in a group of
friends right they'll be like hey man
you cook really good you should open a
restaurant okay you know what you sing
really good have you ever thought about
being a singer and everyone keeps
telling your grandma goes oh honey you
played a piano so well you should be
professional like everyone starts off
this way right they get it in their
heads and they're like you know what
maybe I should be a singer maybe I
should you know yeah and they [ __ ]
make a video and people like you [ __ ]
suck and they're like oh what or like
you know they think they're funny and
[ __ ] and they're like yeah man you're
[ __ ] funny dude and then everyone
eggs Amman and then like your buddy they
do the stand-up thing and it doesn't
work out like I have a friend you know
this [ __ ] he is funny like tears funny
because he's such a [ __ ] potty mouth
[ __ ] right he's impulsive and
he's crazy and I'm like this guy would
do so well on camera hmm every time we
[ __ ] put him in a skit turn on the
camera he freezes yeah he becomes a
small little man he's all like [ __ ]
cute yeah dude like he wants to hide
from the camera
and when a camera goes off he's all like
oh oh you [ __ ] Oh [ __ ] [ __ ] this
[ __ ] that hey you were like yeah it's
like it's [ __ ] nuts
yeah it's it's such a weird art man and
you everybody has to start from
somewhere if I if I could give a big
advice okay I said I'm not a great
stand-up comic there have been a lot of
people who went to my comic shows and
they were cracking up right in the
[ __ ] comments dude don't make me look
like a dumbass but I've done stand-up
and I've never been a great stand-up
comic I've just you know I've gotten
laughs like it's it's I'm not terrible
at it yeah I mean I will never say I'm
terrible at it I think I'm pretty decent
at it but have something to say and have
a point and stick to that point you
can't be a [ __ ] I see people on Twitter
are the worst comics ever because their
wish they're wishy-washy about their
thoughts you have to take a point and
take people on a journey to set them up
for that punchline have a point and say
something whether it's about yourself
your thoughts you have to say something
man did you know that [ __ ] is a slur
now oh really
you can't call people retards what if
they're [ __ ] I think you're not it's
a it's an old word now you can't say it
anymore even for like let's say like
some like a clothing is [ __ ] [ __ ]
up you can't say the clothes is [ __ ]
even though that might be the correct
term like a or like a like they call
like a like a retardant right or like
like yeah like a retardant or whatever
nah dude you can't it's considered a
slur you can't you can't say it isn't
it's wrong I understand if you know when
it comes to people but if my backpacks
jacked up and I say that's [ __ ]
[ __ ]
it's it's an actual word yeah I mean you
can't well yes because I called
everybody that on Twitter and you're
like how dare you how dare you use a
slur and I'm like what well I get let me
go look up the definition of a slur cuz
I just thought it was only you know
racist [ __ ] but like oh it actually is a
slur oh it's a it's I think the
definition of a slur is like like
[ __ ] you know a group of people that
can't defend themselves you know what if
you got like some really [ __ ] up teeth
and I say your teeth are [ __ ]
I think this eligible I'm not saying I
think that's completely okay I don't
think because I'm not calling your your
the mentality I'm not I'm not referring
to a human being no it's a slight
yeah but [ __ ] we can't say no more oh
really well thanks for letting me know I
guess I have to take down all my [ __ ]
tweets yep so now you might be you might
get violated on Twitter for using that
one yeah that smells like oh man I mean
I don't know I didn't know that [ __ ] so
now I'm just gonna say dick face cuz
that's not a slur you could call someone
dick face so [ __ ] face
just wait till somebody has a dick or
yes oh my god they're gonna be like hey
you have rights can you imagine the guy
looking like gonzo with a big [ __ ]
dick coming out of their nose that'd be
[ __ ] hilarious you see this guy with
a dick coming out like right out the
side and he goes how dare you say that
about my people we've had dick faces for
2,000 years we have rights
Japanese Tengu masks Oh [ __ ] dick
faces Tengu dick face there's a lot of
things changing right so like in in in
comedy at least I feel like I have
outdated thoughts or taboo thoughts yeah
and what I realized is we are guilty
pleasures for a lot of Gen Z and young
younger people we don't grow into
millions because like the majority has
changed yeah but the people that still
vibe with us and [ __ ] with us right
because I'll be doing college shows
again and everyone keeps saying watch
out for those college shows watch out
because they're full of [ __ ] sjw
super [ __ ] sensitive and I have a
suspicion it's only the white people I
go down I was in Texas Denton I was in
[ __ ] Boston Chinese Student
Association a [ __ ] Asian Union
everybody we're out there talking and
you know and they were like man we have
a sensitive generation whole [ __ ]
group clap they're like [ __ ] yeah man or
Jerris is too sensitive
yeah and I'm like damn just because
there's people who appreciate comedy and
they understand that within the comedy
realm it there's they're trying to take
something negative and make it funny
yeah that's that's what comedy is it is
you're trying to take a spin and a take
on something that most people like I'll
give this this is a great example right
people have this like it depends on how
your moral barometer sways like it's
it's all person it's all personally
based like for example they go you can't
say like don't you dare talk about
[ __ ]
like don't use the word [ __ ] right
yeah it's a slur yeah right but then
there's a debate on whether [ __ ] is is
acceptable or not yeah right some people
like yr aging people so sensitive about
that
yeah it's like well then what's your
stance then it's like if if if you feel
that way about the word [ __ ] how
come I can't feel that way about the
word [ __ ] yeah and and that's why I'm
saying in comedy it's weird because it's
your moral barometer doesn't have the
same test as everybody else it's
everybody's more bronze different it
goes this way or it goes that way mhm
right depending on who you are as an
individual so I like in comedy as long
as the intent is to make somebody laugh
and there's a joke in it that I can
understand I think like 90% 95% of the
time I'll give it a pass Yeah right even
the ones that I go oh I don't like that
yeah but I know that they're trying to
make a joke out of it and I understand
like the setup and the joke that I'm
like ah it's just a bad joke whatever
sometimes there's no setup
it's just statement yeah it's just them
being a [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah and I think that's the thing about
comedy like it takes a bit of an
understanding of what people are
communicating because people are taking
it literal or they're making it so taboo
that you're not allowed to play with the
idea yeah cuz they're like well it's
like [ __ ] this ain't a [ __ ]
intellectual like philosophy class or a
[ __ ] cultural [ __ ] you know
history class or anything like this is
comedy like you play with thoughts you
[ __ ] around like it's a big [ __ ] joke
but they're taking that and they're
treating it as if it should be something
serious it supposed to be something
educational it's like and I'm like what
are you serious yeah that's as stupid as
like watching a [ __ ] old Ren & Stimpy
cartoon and then getting outraged by it
this podcast is brought to you by skill
share are you about lifelong learning
are you tired of learning the way that
people want you to learn or is there
something that you have been hankering
to learn on your own time on your own
schedule are their hobbies out there are
their skills that you really want to
develop but you really don't know where
to go for it or you want it to be
accessible
to you in a library full of knowledge
well that Skillshare for you baby I've
been using Skillshare now for quite a
few months and I'm telling you right now
my photography skills have been so much
more improved because I needed a lot of
photography knowledge that I didn't have
before and I've been taking some of the
photography classes because I learned on
the fly and I forgot about the
fundamental basics so I went back and he
brushed up on my skills and Skillshare
was there for me if you're about
lifelong learning if you like learning
on your own pace which for me I enjoy
because I could just go through the
whole library of knowledge and learn
when I want to based on my schedule at
the speed that I want well my friends
skills share is for you I do really
believe that people should pursue things
outside of the traditional format of
Education and if there are things that
you want to learn you should go and
learn it at your own time and your own
schedule and your own accord and
Skillshare has got your back baby so
join the millers you join the millions
of students already learning on
Skillshare today with the special offer
just for my listeners get two months a
Skillshare for free that's right
Skillshare is offering genius brain
listeners two months of unlimited access
to thousands of classes for free to sign
up go to Skillshare dot-com slash brain
again go to Skillshare dot-com slash
brain to start your two months now that
Skillshare dot-com slash brain there's
like a lot of comics - I [ __ ] hate
where you could tell that they're just
creating content based on what's current
right now just to get people on their
side you know and it's like oh yeah
you're so [ __ ] woke and they make
jokes about local myths about wellness
and how people are dumb for not being
woken saying come on bro like we already
know what your stick is your stick is
because you're trying to get everybody
on your side so they can suck your
[ __ ] dick yeah you're not really
saying anything man somebody recently
accidentally was somebody 400 people
recently sent me somebody's recent
stand-up set that they put on YouTube
and it was so [ __ ] bad and I wanted
to it only confirmed why this person is
such trash it's like if you ever watch
this video I'm not gonna say who but you
guys already know who the [ __ ] this is
it's like this
what I'm talking about when it comes to
somebody's content and why I don't [ __ ]
with these type of people it's like
you're not saying anything you you
literally just create content just to
get people on your side because you
think it's the hot thing to do so you
want to go viral you want to go there
like women should get paid as much as
men oh you [ __ ] said some dope [ __ ]
yep she's [ __ ] dude her to do dude I
never heard that before yeah
it's like an Asian comic saying only
Asian stuff it's like you know Asian
people you know Asians cuz only less
Asians right now well you don't aegeon
people right it's like shut the f---
what are you [ __ ] saying like for
example in the stand-up said he was
talking about like Vietnamese
stereotypes that don't even exist like
just making up stereotype what you mean
like like you know you know Vietnamese
people love soft-boiled eggs
it'll be on like some [ __ ] like that no
and it's like what are you saying like
why are you just saying things just to
say things but that's what that's what I
[ __ ] hate about stand-up comics like
that it's like you're now you're just
creating stereotypes and [ __ ] just
because you you're trying to create
something to get people on your side so
you know if it nummies people are then
you walk around and you know they have
money and stuff it's like what is the
stereotype coming from they like make
some [ __ ] out yeah and it's just like
that's the same continent when Japanese
people like wearing their kilts yeah
it's like on some [ __ ] like that man
it's like a very low hanging fruit and
you just make our culture look that
[ __ ] bad yeah but at the same time
you want to be a beacon of light for our
culture you're not you're using our
culture and you're trying to prey on
weak people who've been bullied for
being Asian yeah and you're trying to
get them on your side like yeah man yeah
oh are you people this no you're making
us look [ __ ] terrible and I wish that
you would just stop like take a step
back look at what the [ __ ] you're
[ __ ] doing stop demanding people to
respect you just because you have
[ __ ] Chinese a little [ __ ] [ __ ]
eyes like alright like just because we
got small [ __ ] eyes doesn't mean I
gotta [ __ ] [ __ ] what you dude and
it's this is the problem it makes us
look bad it does because one of the
questions that I had from a student in
Boston he was like hey you guys are
pretty prominent like an Asian community
and do you ever feel the responsibility
to speak out or speak against like
injustice
bored us and all that stuff and I'm like
I never want to represent the Asian
community because one look at how I
[ __ ] run my mouth am I the best role
model for this [ __ ] [ __ ] no and I don't
want to be a role model I'm just gonna
say what other [ __ ] I want and be
responsible for myself I love my Asians
but on top of that I won't speak on
behalf as if I am the voice of the
people like that should be voted right
that kind of [ __ ] should be like
everyone gets together and be like I
like to stand up [ __ ] you should
do it but [ __ ] anybody that goes on our
behalf and says as an asian-american I
should be like this and I'm like [ __ ]
you man I didn't vote you in I don't
know I don't give a [ __ ] about you you
know you don't represent me [ __ ] you hey
the [ __ ] Asian UN ambassadors I woke
up and I was like guys you shouldn't
feel that either anybody that does that
be careful because why should we back
them up we don't know if they're rapists
we don't know if they're [ __ ] dirty
piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] girlfriend beaten
ass like why should we blindly back the
[ __ ] up out of people because we're the
same race me I give my loyalty to my
best friends and people that I spent
time with that's that's my tribe that's
why I care about and that's how that's
who you should do be dealing with don't
put race above family and friends don't
do that [ __ ] and a lot of people do that
[ __ ] cuz why everybody just only hangs
out with their own [ __ ] race man and
I think that's the stupidest [ __ ]
because it's like this like if we do get
into a race battle right and people want
to fight with like I don't know like
let's say we get into a Asian versus
Mexican thing right what if my [ __ ]
wife is Mexican what if my best friend
is Mexican is this like gang [ __ ] it's
like I'm gonna have to [ __ ] turn my
back on them and then get with these
other [ __ ] Asian strangers and fight
together walk that man yeah I don't
believe in that [ __ ] yeah it's it's it's
weird too yeah that's a very good
question that they asked it's like do
you feel responsible I don't know if I
ever feel responsible because I only
talked about Asian stuff because I'm
talking about it from personal
experience yeah so when I do a
Vietnamese accent it's because I grew up
with the [ __ ] ton of Vietnamese people
and I know so that's your experience my
experience I know what it's like to kick
it what a bunch of
these people right that's why I could
say these random [ __ ] Vietnamese
phrases that I know is that I didn't
learn it out of noetic google it it's
just I heard it my whole life you know I
was around vitamins people so much i
explicitly only dative it amis girls yes
what I knew I wish these girls are
beautiful yes they are there's no man
love you and um nice I'll buy cold beer
huh you know what how come you're not
drinking beer oh it was my pickup line
dude but I wouldn't your net number and
I saw my Columbia so I used to say I
should all the time but you know not not
not to you know get off track it's just
I I speak from things that I know of
right when I talk about Chinese
stereotypes or whatever it's because I
grew up around these type of Chinese
people when I talk about like East
elation is because I was around a lot of
East LA Mexicans when I came to LA yeah
you know like I can't talk about stuff I
don't know about I'm not gonna just say
these jokes because I heard it through
somebody else it doesn't come from a
[ __ ] honest place yeah so when you do
this stand up really think about who you
are what you want to say and the things
that you want to talk about you have to
solidify that [ __ ] first that stand up
comes from pain hell yeah dude you know
how many stories I got where my god I
got my [ __ ] ass beat and then people
laugh at me on JK news about it like
that wasn't a bit but you know what
laughing the way I tell the story I
guess but that's like the but dude you
don't even know how great of a stand-up
you would be if you just know when
you're making a good joke I know right
I'm just like you have the [ __ ] I'm
just talking bro the best jokes but it's
always everybody else is laughing it did
you're like I think I just made a joke I
know
sometimes I'm just talking especially on
Jackie news is like I'm it's just just
like this I'm just running my head right
in my mouth you know and then I'm like
oh I made a funny well [ __ ] it
oh well I did a funny yeah man if I
could write that [ __ ] down and then I
can execute it I think he'll be much
better but yeah man just just be smart
about what you put out always work on
your craft write your jokes down see
what see what doesn't work but you just
have to try I you know Joe Rogan said it
best he goes if you go up and you're in
a comedy club you grab a mic and you
make jokes you're a stand-up comic you
may not be a great one right now
but there are people who have done
stand-up comedy who great people have
told them that they don't have it and
they ended up being really great because
they worked on it they worked on their
craft don't let other people tell you if
you're good or you're bad
just [ __ ] keep doing it and you tell
yourself that yeah like I could even the
people that I talk [ __ ] about that I
[ __ ] hate they might be something
amazing later yeah and I don't have to
eat those words that's just how I feel
right now just because I have an opinion
about somebody's art it doesn't mean
that somebody else doesn't appreciate it
yeah shoutouts to the fan bros man you
know what I mean like I love them dude
anybody who talks [ __ ] about them dude
you guys can suck my dick man hey they
they love I love them dude they they had
they talk they have so much stuff to
talk about fitnah me stereotypes you
know just what Asian people are and they
are prominent members of the Asian
community and we should respect them as
such all right in fact Wong foo the fact
that you didn't put them in Asian
bachelor makes me very upset you the
fing Brossart fill a pillar of our
community man you should go watch up go
watch Daniel fangs stand up it is
exactly why I love him representing our
own oh my [ __ ] shoutouts to the fan bros
man baby yo I'll say this right now
Danny Feng might be something great and
I don't mean I don't mean that in a in a
in a those are my heroes right he might
turn out to be great Ellie she's up
there making Asian people look great
making Asian great again making Asians
great of Magha dude daniel-san [ __ ]
bag I'm gonna wear a mag ahead and it's
for my gang man making Asians great
again dude shoutout student that is [ __ ]
you see I always questioned people that
want to like do it for the Asians yeah
like what does that mean like I know I
don't I don't get it like what who are
you performing for and who are you
trying to impress cuz like it's kind of
narcissistic if you think about it right
you think black people are standing
there waiting and going like what count
oh this is what Asians are like or like
or like white people like finally
respecting us or whatever like I don't
give a [ __ ] about their pain
I just want to make dope content great
art and [ __ ] create content that
services the public right yeah let's put
our culture on our backs by doing
something great and you don't have to
listen even if I don't say I'm Asian I'm
pretty sure you could tell by my Gucci
ass face that I'm Asian yeah like you
could tell I don't need to keep telling
you and rubbing it in your [ __ ] face
yeah if I do something great that and by
the way a lot of the comedy that you've
seen from me sketch is wise go look at a
Korean comedy it's it's Korean comedy
yeah
even even that comedy that you saw a
little bit in [ __ ] those funny moments
that's a Korean thing yeah a lot of
serious Korean films always have a
little jokes in it that's that's where I
represent my culture I don't need to
explicitly say it but I'm glad that
Asian Americans can look at see what I'm
doing and be like that's dope makes me
feel good as the Asian but I don't have
to shove that message down your throat
yeah I just have to do great things and
do stuff that represents me as a person
and if you [ __ ] with that you [ __ ] with
it yeah I feel like that was really
important to me you know like pioneering
Asian American comedy when I first got
started so there is a time and place for
that kind of motivation because there
was nothing there like MADtv didn't
represent us and I and I saw in living
color and I'm like that's dope cuz it's
a it's a voice of their people in a
style that's comedy that's tears right
and I'm like we don't have nothing
that's ours right but it's always been
like a service to the people where it's
like I want to make jokes and stories of
things I relate with you know but it was
never this like let me show why people
was yeah I'm not trying to prove anybody
to anything I'm just trying to create
something that we can enjoy so I think
when it comes to being motivated by
cultural voids that's the best approach
I think people should have is like you
don't have anything to prove to anyone
like it's it's it's [ __ ] dope to say
I'm gonna put Asians on a map or
whatever but the but the core motivator
should be hey we're missing this let's
fill it up okay so like we're missing
[ __ ] stories about Asian Casanova's
whatever right but I mean
they go too far like a lot of these
dudes are like man we need a [ __ ]
story about an Asian player that's
[ __ ] all these white [ __ ] and all
this stuff I don't know man like it's
it's it's to me it's like insel gross
weird [ __ ] yeah like that's not real
Casanova [ __ ] like that's that's that's
[ __ ] kind of disgustingly weird
that's like guy that's addicted to
prostitutes and that's no different from
a weird you know foreigner that goes to
Southeast Asia and gets a you know wife
there because they can't get a girl in
their own home country like there's some
weird [ __ ] right so like and I kind of
see that behavior in like these insell
Asian dudes that are like like man we
need to get a [ __ ] Asian guy that
represents that that's why I can't get
any [ __ ] girls cuz this and that and
I'm like dude shut the [ __ ] up I know
some ugly as Asian dudes that can bag
women non-stop because they know how to
speak and flirt and make them feel
awesome and all that stuff yeah yeah I
think I think that's the type of
mentality that I did I'm disgusted by
because it's it to me I'm like whoa
let's make that movie to fill that void
but what people are saying is like hey I
want this movie made so then it's gonna
increase my ability to [ __ ] a white girl
or some huge [ __ ] like you know it's
like no just make it because we want to
tell love stories about Asian culture
it's not represented and we do have
romance we do have relationships we do
have love stories wrong food is a good
example like they show the love stories
and things that happen in our community
right and I'm like let's do more of that
yeah and I don't want people to get
things twisted for me it's like it's not
that just because you don't have the
same sensibility as I do it doesn't mean
that I don't [ __ ] with your [ __ ] I can
have an opinion about not liking your
stuff right that's completely okay
however I also can respect what you do
yeah you know like I mean let's just be
real like with you know Wong foo stuff I
say like you know 80% of their [ __ ] I'm
not gonna vibe with because it's not my
style it doesn't speak to you this is
speak to me you respect them as creators
yes 100% yes they are speaking to what
they know best and it still reverberates
with what other people like I cannot
like any of their stuff but I can still
respect what they [ __ ] do yeah I
don't
never see me call like you know throw
shade at them you know know that that
[ __ ] parody that I did wasn't
throwing shade at Wong foo I was just my
version of what I would do with their
style of videos right right so maybe
this video called the last resort and
they did a video called the last yeah
and I parodied it not to make fun of
what they were doing it's just like if I
did a drama love thing I would do it
this is how I would do it yeah and it's
in my voice and that's what I enjoy you
know and it's not it's not we can always
disagree with somebody's art I'm still
like them as people
oh yeah and that's what I think that's
what people can't do man
yeah it's like when you say I don't like
this guy's movie doesn't mean that I
don't like him as a human being yeah
doesn't mean they're not cool doesn't
mean they're not funny yeah yeah I mean
not everybody can be perfectly okay I
told Steve straight up I was like I only
watched internet-famous because because
of you I didn't like that movie yeah
it's not my style it's I mean like it's
a good movie don't get me wrong it's
like it's not for me
yeah so I I supported you and I think
it's [ __ ] cool but I personally can't
even quote on it because that's not the
kind of movie that I walk in watch yeah
and that's me being a hardhead
right like it's not even like because he
asked me what I thought and I'm like I
didn't like it because it's not
something that I would watch yeah it's
like and that's okay too like I there's
a lot of films that I [ __ ] don't
really like like um people really love
to drive because it's so aesthetic and
beautiful but that movie was boring as
[ __ ] man I hated the dialogue in it it
was so sparse but that's what that
director was going for it that's cool it
looked beautiful I didn't really like it
it is what it is and it's okay to say I
don't like this I don't like that
whatever foe this podcast is brought to
you by purple the company that creates
the purple mattress that has been
helping people nationwide get the best
sleep of their lives including me I
slept on the crappiest beds my whole
life and I didn't know how blessed I
could be sleeping on a purple mattress
and my friends you guys already know
that sleeping is a huge part of our
lives it affects everything if you're
sleeping on a crappy mattress I
guarantee that you are sleeping terrible
and the purple mattress has the
technology has the comfort has
everything that'll help you get the best
sleep of your life ever since I switched
I've been sleeping so well and I got to
tell you the fact that it's firm it's
soft it's like the perfect amount of
cush you know what I mean it's like you
don't really sink into into it too much
and you don't and it's not so firm where
it hurts your back it's that perfect
balance and that's really hard to find
in a mattress and purple has perfected
it
so my friends check it out you're going
to love purple and right now my
listeners will get a free purple pillow
with the purchase of a mattress that's
in addition to the great free gifts
they're offering site-wide just text
brain to 84-88 the only way to get this
amazing free pillow is the text brain
into eight four - eight eight eight
that's B R a I n two eight four eight
eight eight message and data rates may
apply yeah and even sometimes when
people are for example with you you're
like well I have stand-up like I don't
know if I'm gonna be good of stand-up
whether I tell you're gonna be good or
bad at or not there is a 50/50 chance
that I might be right or wrong that's
how it is you could be terrible right
now and you can get better at it there's
so many stories of super successful
people to that we're told no like jay-z
like he was told no no no no one would
[ __ ] make his like bring him on the
label so he made his own label mm-hmm so
I think that people who can take all the
knows and keep fighting and they still
get and then they get what they want I
think they actually deserve it like this
world the way that it's designed it's
made to weed out the [ __ ] weak yeah
so if you want to be successful while
people are still lifting you up and you
don't have to face any adversity you're
a [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah a hundred percent
do not expect that and if you walk into
the world expecting a lot of support a
lot of love a lot of all this stuff man
the world is a cold [ __ ] place just
expect that those things are extra but
you should expect people to go against
your wishes you should expect family in
France to talk [ __ ] and hurt your
feelings you it sucks but expect that
and when someone does give you love and
support I think it makes it that much
more rewarding when you hear it
you're like oh thanks do you anything
yeah and you know even for me when I
started doing stand-up I was arguably
really terrible not I'm not great now
you know I'm decent but you know if I
and I truly believe this is myself if I
sat here and I went to comedy clubs
every [ __ ] night and I own this
[ __ ] crowd who get better I will get
better I know for a fact I will you know
it's just a matter of how much how much
do you want it you know if you if you
really if if stand-up is something for
you that you just want to try just
[ __ ] try it doesn't matter if you're
good or bad or not if you want to give
it a go just give it a [ __ ] go in
most cases if people just get out of
their heads right and quit [ __ ]
overthinking and they just keep doing it
and thought about the affective [ __ ]
like let's say he's how many hours is
this [ __ ]
spend thinking about should I do
stand-up a lot of people do that
[ __ ] right instead of shut up
start writing jokes start writing jokes
start writing jokes start going into
[ __ ] comedy clubs doing it getting
booed go to another one go to another
one write notes write notes write jokes
do that [ __ ] spend all the time
complaining and wondering and ruminating
all those hours flip it in just doing
the actual work you're gonna [ __ ]
kill it it's the simplest [ __ ] I don't
know why people can't do it it drives me
crazy and um plugging in Jojo Marlene
academy.com but that's this frustration
is why I created [ __ ] like this yeah is
coz like to me it's so simple that's why
dude I don't even work as hard as a lot
of people we know but I'm looked upon as
successful because I know the recipe
yeah I just put work into it and when
I'm when we're here it's simple you see
it we all see it right I never had a
problem with just doing it I always knew
it was like okay I just had to [ __ ]
do the work I'm a lazy ass I got to do
the work yeah and you'll [ __ ] kill it
in and so we have a personal trainer he
said the same [ __ ] like you and David
you guys are [ __ ] so easy to work
with man yeah you I've David lost what
60 pounds yeah because I lost weight but
I got cut with him nick is like it's
amazing working with you guys it's
almost like I'm not working and I'm like
what are you talking about
and he's like most people they need a
lot of emotional support a lot of like
minders like motivation he goes you guys
don't need any of that all you need is
like what are the steps to be successful
you guys do that you guys go home do
research and then you enhance what I
give to you on your own you do extra
credit and then you come back and then
you're progressing but most people they
don't know how to do that and I'm like
well that's why most people can't get
anywhere in life
yeah it's so simple just do the [ __ ]
work why is that so hard yeah but yeah
yeah just don't you know if you want to
try stand-up give it a go and and a lot
of people just don't expect yourself to
be amazing at something when you just
started it's not gonna happen that way
there are a few people out there that
are really gifted but let those one
percenters you know be happy and they're
quick little glory a majority of us do
have to work hard for what we do I can
give you as much as advice as you want
to start stand-up because I'm just still
in the beginning phases of it I mean I
have done shows with a thousand people
and the people I like your set though
funny man yeah you know we've we've done
and you'll go see me do stand-up you
know so yeah it's it's something that's
very difficult it takes time to develop
like even now if you put me up on stage
right now I probably bombed because I
haven't done it in so long yeah but you
know if you let me bomb a couple times
and then find my pacing let me find my
timing and I'll get better dude let me
tell you something man David Feng he he
went out there and he put himself out
there he okay all jokes aside right this
guy [ __ ] sucks all right I'll just be
real you guys if you guys go to a
standard so a bunch of people send me
their [ __ ] because they wanted me to
critique it yeah there's nothing to
critique why critique it I don't know
but they every time something they do
something that people said it would be
good to do because I've been doing this
ongoing joke I mean this is just this is
just a joke by the way
it's just it's just odd going now so it
makes me laugh but his stand-up set
seeing it and he knows it too it was
[ __ ] garbage it was trash not and you
know there's a lot to say to commend
somebody for going out there and trying
to do stand-up I saw him do stand-up 10
years ago when I first started it was
trash then and still trashed now and the
reason why is because in his case it's
not good because he has nothing to say
and that's my best advice a lot of their
content - it's it kind of just begs on
them holding onto this Asian I
anything Asian people this Asian people
that we've moved past that now we move
past it so now you have to think and you
have to adjust and you have to think on
your feet what am I saying as a comic
what is the point that I'm trying to
make why am i saying these things am I
just saying these things because it's
something that's a part of my branding
or am i saying something to really say
something and connect with people
comedy connects people you're supposed
to make people laugh and make people
think and even if you don't make people
think you're you're supposed to have
your content be about you that's the
best type of [ __ ] oh yeah like nobody
look the more I expose about myself the
more people laugh exactly that's then
that's like the great thing about it
dude I'll use Kevin Hart as an example
right Kevin Hart he doesn't have a lot
of like thought-provoking [ __ ] but I
should so [ __ ] relatable it makes you
laugh yeah if you've if you've seen his
stand-up specials on TV versus him in
person in person I was in tears laughing
when I saw it on [ __ ] Netflix it's
better in her say in person tears like
it was that [ __ ] funny because you
could feel his presence on stage he has
an amazing stage presence cause he's
such a big presence for such a lady he
got that he got that [ __ ] dude he got
that Julius Caesar no man he command a
[ __ ] sea of people dude who don't
want that yeah and he has that type of
[ __ ] you know for somebody you know when
you guys sent me Danny fing [ __ ] it was
like come on bro like cut that Asian
[ __ ] out dude if you don't have anything
to say about our culture your culture
where you grew up from what you're
thinking and you have to make up
stereotypes just to just to try to
relate to people yeah and then use like
oh you know [ __ ] Asian people and and
he starts doing this shitty Vietnamese
accent if you can't do the vintner my
exit dumbu's it okay don't do it my ass
you could tell he didn't really go out
with Vietnamese people well he's using
the accent because he knows that other
people use it in to make people so it's
not coming from a genuine it's not it's
like a lot of mimic mimicking its
mimicry dude and I don't like that dude
and nobody even even even like you see
like the the list of people they're like
this was terrible it was bad if your
fans can't even [ __ ] back you up bro
then you have a problem here and it's
the problem that you have you got away
with it on YouTube but you're not gonna
get away with it on stand-up because now
you're working with real human beings
who want to hear some [ __ ] who want to
[ __ ] laugh yeah so step your game up
if you want if you want to be a stand-up
comic and you really want it and you're
not doing it just because it's a hot
[ __ ] thing to do then have something
to say yeah that's all I'm gonna say
right
that's true man that's good at vent
that's really good advice yeah like I
don't I'm not like I'd make all these
jokes about him only because you know
just because it's [ __ ] funny at this
point you know but if that human being
can improve his content and really if if
you want to be like Asian you want to be
the Andrew yang of our [ __ ] group
then do something yeah do something
about it man
don't don't don't keep on doing this
sorry little Asian stick I don't want to
be I love I love being Asian and I love
being asian-american but I don't want
that responsibility cuz I love being a
[ __ ] yeah there's so much
responsibility that comes with like
representing a whole group of people you
gotta be Andrew yang I think he's a
clean-cut [ __ ] and I love it for
in the repartee I wanna call people
[ __ ] I want to openly talk about
loving to get my [ __ ] salad tossed in
it my dream is to get two girls sucking
on my dick and like like that I can't do
that anymore if I become a
representation of the culture you know
what I mean like I want to talk about a
lot of the mistakes I made in life and
all the drugs that I've done and how
great cracking makes with [ __ ] weed
and [ __ ] like ro I want to talk about
the homes I bought into in the gambling
I've done and like hashtag Joe hos dunno
yang gang do Joe hos and I can't I can't
do that if I become the role model for a
representation that's too much [ __ ]
weight to carry man and and I I don't
want it but it's like if people look up
to me that's all you that's you brother
that's that's your fault I never told
you look up to me yeah but if you keep
asking me questions and you like my
lifestyle I'm gonna give it because I
love to help and I love to make people
feel free I think that's where I want to
be a role model that's where that's
where the thing is like freedom right
like the freedom to unapologetically
live the way you are because this is
your personality yeah I think too many
people are there they're hidden there
they're afraid and a lot of problems and
insecurities rise from them not being
aligned with their own greatness right
so like a lot of people they're there
they resent a lot because they're like
especially in the Asian community it's
like my
parents forced me to be a pharmacist or
a doctor but what I really wanted to do
was [ __ ] in you know build cars or
whatever and it's like man that sucks
yeah you couldn't thrive you couldn't
you couldn't live your own life like in
for me I think I really push the
boundaries on how far I can get away
with saying things that I want to living
the way that I want to spending the way
that I want to [ __ ] who I want to you
know breathing wherever I want to
whatever you know like traveling what I
want to like doing all these things
right I push the boundaries and I keep
doing it and I vlog that [ __ ] and I'm
all like what can I get a get away with
and then the opposite happens is no one
really looks at me and goes that's
inappropriate they go I want to do that
yeah you're so free like and I'm like
I'm not even being free or trying to
prove anything I'm just being me but I
like and the more I mean the more I
express and talk a lot of people go how
do I not give a [ __ ]
well easy here's here's how you do it
step by step it's [ __ ] easy yes it
literally is there's there's it's it's I
think for a lot of people was easier
said than done because of their personal
inhibitions right if I don't know if
this will ever sink into your head but
it was something that it was so simple
that it I have to tell myself this all
the [ __ ] time when I try something
new that scares me you're not gonna
[ __ ] die
oh do you die are you gonna die you die
then don't matter man don't complain
don't complain [ __ ] yeah but that's
really what it is I'm not gonna die from
it
yeah I'm really not like you try new
things in a social setting or trying
things that you really want to do but
you're scared to do at the end of it if
you come out alive in your breathing and
you have all [ __ ] ten toes and ten
fingers and you have your eyesight and
nothing has changed you've only gained
something and you haven't lost [ __ ] so
if you're scared to do something there
you'll die then oh come on you know you
know one of my things that I want to do
too is if I had to think of cultural
specific what is saint-just Asian
culture man this is just cult-like like
society in general right is like
we're battling with this idea of
masculinity and like [ __ ] it's just
it's just an interesting time we're
living in right and like I really want
to help shape the minds and bring boys
into men because like well for one a lot
of us have grown up in broken homes with
no good male figures right yeah there's
a lot of irresponsible boys out there
that pop out children and they or not
they're horrible [ __ ] role models
yeah
we have absent dads that are in the home
but they're absent in parenting we don't
have a good representation of what it
means what it means to be a leader in
our community right like in a lot of it
is like a lot of people might be hyper
aggressive because they're
overcompensating and they're like that's
what a man is a lot of people might be
like you know just so focused on work
and just paying the bills because that's
what their dad did and they don't know
how to be involved with the family
because that's what a man is and no one
has this description of what it is right
but when I see a lot of Asian males I
look at them and I'm all like why you
complaining you [ __ ] hmm be a [ __ ]
man yeah and to me a man is like someone
who takes and rolls with the punches and
even though you know the modern man is
someone who's able to express feelings
and not deny them and not suppress them
and recognizes they're there but a real
man has courage right so like regardless
if you're afraid or whatever it's like
you you recognize those feelings instead
of suppressing and baring them but you
still have the courage to walk through
and execute and get your [ __ ] [ __ ]
done yeah and not crumble and that's the
whole thing right there's too many
little [ __ ] complaining these days
and they still want what they want it's
like simply put if you're complaining
you don't deserve getting laid mmm so if
you're complaining about girls don't
like you if you're complaining about
like this and that it's so hard to date
it's so hard to that it's like shut up
dude you don't deserve anything because
you're sitting there complaining
like a little [ __ ] [ __ ] if you shut
the [ __ ] up do the work move forward
have some courage if I can take those
damn punches and walk for that's what
people in general want from others like
that's what I want from a leader I want
someone who's able to walk through a
reign full of punches and come out alive
I'll follow that [ __ ]
that's what women want in a husband they
want someone that's not gonna [ __ ] out
and crumble what's gonna happen with two
little [ __ ] in a relationship and
it's like yeah we have equality and all
that but like naturally women do not
want to lead they don't want to be the
one that's like [ __ ] taking care of
[ __ ] while their [ __ ] husbands like
weak and crying like a little [ __ ] cuz
he can't get a job and all this [ __ ]
yeah like who the [ __ ] wants that or at
least equal you know yeah and it's like
what do you expect and it does start I
mean I could only speak about the male
experience right like I don't know how
to make a woman so it might sound like
kind of gender specific but I'm not
trying to rule out girls I just don't
know how to make a girl into a woman but
in my case I think the world would be
better if we know how to build men and a
lot of guys think they are but they
don't know what the [ __ ] that means yeah
I think it's hard because man I've
talked about this before to where I
think we can get to a whole nother
podcast about this but we won't but
people may they'll be the next pocket
yeah like people shy away from personal
responsibility and I think that's the
biggest thing about being an adult yeah
you know personal responsibility
understanding that the things that you
do have an action and a reaction so you
can't things just don't [ __ ] happen
for a reason you know they're they're
there you have to come to a point in
your life where you have to understand
what personal responsibility is that
these things happen because of stuff
that you've done not everything but
things just don't [ __ ] happen yeah
you know you know what I mean yeah like
I hate it when there's like
relationships between two people that
kind of fall apart and they go it's all
your fault yes all your well that's
because there's two [ __ ] dumb [ __ ]
who don't understand personal
responsibility these things happen
because of what both you people did it's
so fun to blame the other person don't
that's fine you're like [ __ ] you this
[ __ ] dumbass yeah it's like if I um
if I walked around and I went to
[ __ ] Crypt neighborhood and I was
like blood blood blood and I got shot up
right and they're like well it's it's
free speech why can't I just say I
should not have to live in a world where
I can't scream blood and not get shot
very true too bad you walked into a [ __ ]
neighborhood that's not what the world
is like there's personal responses and
ideally you still have to rap but you
[ __ ] do in reality there are things
that we want in this world that we think
how it should be and we are a hundred
percent right but the reality is it's
not like that you know what that's
called delusion yeah it's [ __ ]
delusional right and today listen it's
like even during this time and I think
like I'm I'm I'm very like pro-women I'm
all that other [ __ ] right and I think
sometimes there's like a small percent
of women that [ __ ] up for like the
big group I mean that's every group
right yeah every group has that yeah
like there's always that small [ __ ]
group of guys that [ __ ] it up for us and
that small group of women that [ __ ] it
up for women and it's like like for
example we did this Jake a news article
about these girls who went to South
America and they went into a very bad
neighborhood all the locals told them
like yo don't go out at this time it's
very bad there's bad people you beat
your gunshots at night and they walked
around they're like [ __ ] that like you
know women shouldn't have to do blah
blah blah booty shorts oh no I think
they got kidnapped or some [ __ ] oh right
or something right and the biggest
argument that I was we got Twitter's
like well don't blame these women for
you know don't blame the women for
getting when nobody's blaming them for
being raped I'm blaming their stupidity
I'm blaming the fact that there was
ignorance on their part to say that this
part of South America in this country
should adhere to the lifestyle that they
expect out of these people at in that
area in that bad area right not all of
South America's like that but in that
specific area it's a very bad
neighborhood yeah so it's like it's the
same example of like I'm not gonna walk
into a [ __ ] neighborhood wearing all
[ __ ] red
it's like those dumbass hippie white
kids that [ __ ] the that went to Isis
territory and they're like we're gonna
show them that it is actually okay and
then they wanted a [ __ ] bike across
and it's all love and guess what
happened they got kidnapped and murdered
exactly because it's all love baby you
know what I mean like they're [ __ ]
delusional yeah and you know don't take
sound bites from this podcast listen
listen to what I'm saying it's not wrong
for you to want to live in a world like
that we all want to live in a world like
obviously yeah would you
to wrap your expectations in reality and
understand that's a future that we can
work towards but if that's not the case
you can't look back at it and then blame
what happened on everybody else when you
had an option to not do that yeah that's
like me going to a poor country and
piling a [ __ ] tower of money in the
middle of a poor village and then saying
nobody take it cuz stealing is not
allowed yeah and then everyone [ __ ]
takes it and I'm like oh people are
terrible people are too why are they
stealing why yeah it's like [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] is wrong with you
like right people are [ __ ] crazy man
yeah like wrap your expectations in
[ __ ] reality understand that there's
personal responsibility I want I want
those things [ __ ] - I would love it
and let's all work towards a better
world but let's also realize that it's
not the case right now so let's let's
keep our wits about us you know it's
like that's like I love I would love a
world without war right but there's a
lot of people that go you know what if
we don't disarm first and if we don't
[ __ ] do take the first move of coming
together then everyone else will not
follow suit so we need to take the first
step and disarm all of our military and
then and then everyone else would do it
we got your [ __ ] mind exactly but
there are people that believe that you
disarm yourself first [ __ ] [ __ ] that
share our people that [ __ ] believe
that dude and I have I have a family
member that is that [ __ ] delusional
yeah are you [ __ ] out of your mind I
know right they're like oh why like why
can't we just everybody love you know
like why do we have to fight like if I
was in a bad neighborhood and if someone
was but was to rob me I'll give it to
them I'll give them money I do I'm like
but the world isn't a pacifist yeah like
why should everyone adhere to your
standards of living yeah and like you
might be strong enough to sit there and
be a punching bag and you might be okay
with giving your [ __ ] vagina up or
whatever if someone comes and rapes you
or dude does all these dangerous things
right like you might be completely okay
with that but also why should everyone
comply with your standards yeah if I
want to protect
myself and kill somebody because they're
trying to [ __ ] me up rob my [ __ ]
whatever that's my right to to protect
myself to act violently if someone's
going to do that to me and cause injury
to prevent injury yeah so they couldn't
wrap their mind around that yeah they're
like but isn't it better to just love
first and you'll never be guilty if you
if you don't harm them back you do you
want to harm people and I'm like yeah I
want to harm but that's my arm you yeah
that's my right to protect myself right
but it's like what the [ __ ]
mamaan mind I'm like okay I can't talk
to everyone the same way
no not everyone's gonna understand yeah
I just got to sit there and smile and be
like I don't want to argue yeah it's too
hard to argue with people like that
right and the sad thing is it's like
when these things happen like for
example those girls who went to South
America I know don't quote me on this
but you can find the JK news I remember
the exact story but some bad [ __ ] happen
to him it might even be worse than what
I said and you know I think I think like
the opinion at the time was like what
the [ __ ] were those girls thinking and
there were certain comments that we're
saying yo you know she was why are you
guys normalizing rape nobody's
normalizing [ __ ] rape it's a terrible
terrible [ __ ] thing but we can also
say too when somebody makes a poor
choice yeah to tell the this to tell the
rest of the world to adhere what they
believe in when it's not the reality
that's that's the world has said it and
why is it wrong to make fun of stupidity
I don't know like you can't you can't
argue at me and say that that that
choice wasn't it was stupid it was a
dumb choice
that's like me wearing like fifty gold
chains in the poorest country in the
world and expecting not to be robbed
yeah poor choices
that's like me leaving a rolls-royce
unlocked with the key inside the [ __ ]
ignition and it's running and I'm in the
worst [ __ ] part of town yeah it's
[ __ ] dumb dude like that that's
that's like a girl is [ __ ] beautiful
as hell no one to where she's just bent
over booty spread out and a guy [ __ ]
comes up and has sex with her she's like
oh my god I can't believe you did that
hey what the [ __ ] did I give a great
example do my brother's ex-girlfriend
she was [ __ ] move
[ __ ] in and out of her car right moving
[ __ ] in and out of her car like yes it
was that night or some [ __ ] left her key
fob in the car broad daylight all of all
of her [ __ ] [ __ ] in there and then
she gets her [ __ ] car jacked yeah and
she goes I had the worst luck that's not
luck [ __ ] that's stupidity that's
stupidity you dumb [ __ ] that's not
[ __ ] worst luck on [ __ ] are you
talking about how dare you say that's
luck you know what luck is bad luck is
bad luck is you looking into a boat
captains eyes and he says in 20 years
that I've done this there has never been
a single wave that has ever gotten onto
this boat and then that wave dodges
everybody on the boat hits you directly
in the mouth and soaks all your Dove
equipment better bad then your camera
goes yeah those monks whisper smoke
comes out that's bad luck [ __ ] all
right I when that should happen to me on
a boat I tried to give the boat captain
a tip he wouldn't take it
he said I'm okay bro you keep that for
yourself cuz I lost my phone and my
camera that day oh my god that's bad
luck I don't want to hear you leaving a
key fob and all your [ __ ] in your
[ __ ] car oh my god and then you say I
had the worst luck ever I can't catch a
break no you can catch a [ __ ] case
for saying some that stupid know without
stupid people though we wouldn't have
these funny stories well that's right
that's so true that that's what I that's
what I love is like I mean I I sound
[ __ ] bothered but I'm not you know we
just talk like hello emotional but it
doesn't make me lose sleep or any [ __ ] I
think people are the most fascinating
and interesting things on earth
especially me like I said I'm I'm living
a [ __ ] movie like in my own brain
right like cuz like I have my logical
brain but I also have my animal brain
right and it's like I have this part of
me that is observing everything that's
going and this other part of me that's
like a gorilla that can't control it
yeah it's like you witnessed this I'm
like okay I think I'm done gambling and
I take three steps [ __ ] do a 180 slam
that [ __ ] on all red and I said
200 on red and guess what it goes on
black and I go [ __ ] I've seen this will
come up so hard in gambling and we're
like I'm done for the night I'll turn
away all I hear is this distant Japanese
boy is it
we'll lose all our [ __ ] no matter what
night thrill you love the [ __ ] thrill
dude I do and that's my impulsive stupid
human side yeah what's that the ED or
whatever I forgot what that what the CID
the ego in the super-ego yeah but I
forgot which one is which but you got
one of those [ __ ] and that
[ __ ] is on gas a red rip
reptilian brain yeah yeah you definitely
like the whole gambling side man I think
that's just like a huge part of you that
you're gonna be dealing with for the
rest of your life I also gamble with a
lot of other things in life including
eating out hookers most people go all
you should do is having sex you should
have just had sex with her and I'm like
I know I shouldn't have done it
her mouth went down there and I went to
town
why do you know how many dicks that have
been in there do you know how I don't
know I gambled then I got tested euro
clean so gamble and i won right so good
why would you do that why why would I'm
the only [ __ ] [ __ ] that tries to
have romantic sex with the [ __ ]
process [ __ ] yeah yeah let me eat that
[ __ ] out it's like what dude she should
be servicing me god damn I'm an idiot
she's like I don't know I don't you know
how this works sir I know but you get
it's like I pay her to [ __ ] please
her and [ __ ] god dammit she just feels
great you grow a little better if you
let her know everything's okay
let me listen to your problems here like
I'm like the therapist that [ __ ] pays
the patient to listen to their problems
that's so [ __ ] Wow [ __ ] it in the
whole time in my mind I'm like this is
not a smart thing to do but it's the
thrill and the chase that makes it feel
good I don't know yeah it's and it's I'm
like I'm like I'm yeah I'm - two people
living in one man and I think that's the
fascinating and funny thing about humans
it's like you have this genius everyone
has this genius that knows what the [ __ ]
is right and wrong and all this stuff
but they also have this gorilla
that just does whatever the [ __ ] they
want that stupid grow that shits in
their hands and throws it it on people
and pees all over and jacks off in
public and like that gorilla is [ __ ]
hard to control me it is you know what's
interesting I think for me because I
grew up with like such like bad
temperament issues I think the more I
trained I thought I was gonna calm me
down more it makes me want to fight more
well cuz it's triggering your anxiety
more in addition it's like oh [ __ ] like
I don't know looks like white why do I
like even NIC say the neck says do you
have a lot of [ __ ] hate in your heart
dude you know somebody tags you you try
to you try sleep them like Corian
revenge man I know it's like awful he
hit me hard viola I have to win yeah but
it's [ __ ] acting like it was a peanut
butter jelly sandwich god damnit what is
wrong with me look after you or does she
gave you buddy she gotta have this this
is for you can't even take your tip and
it's just like oh next time come back
[Laughter]
[Music]
never in my life you just become the
talk of the town it's like as for him
he'll pay you and then he'll service you
something's wrong with him he's a giver
in the heat of the moment dude I'm
[ __ ] an animal [ __ ] stupid that's
what I am what am I thinking all the
time yeah I don't know I uh it's it's
just when I'm calm and thinking I can
think really well but most of my life I
live like an animal dude oh it's funny
like oh man in Vietnam like we got
Cooter's right mm-hmm and we're driving
wild and I'm like oh Vietnam traffic
laws are [ __ ] chill like whatever and
so I started daredevil riding with Danny
and I was like let's go against traffic
so what about [ __ ] is going on dude
because it stops I went on the other
side and at the last minute I would
drive off so I'm going against like
playing chicken with the [ __ ] trucks
right and I go a last-minute I move off
to the side and I pull into the side
where the cars are parked so I dodged
the the cars coming by and then [ __ ]
Danny wants to one-up me
so he's like follow me and then we're
riding right and then this fool acts
like he's gonna make a left turn and
then at the very last minute we're at
the edge of the street in the middle of
the intersection he makes a right oh
[ __ ] while cars are coming right so I
have to chase his ass and um we had a
blast just like playing tag with
scooters and afterwards I was thinking
like that wasn't the smartest thing like
you could have died I could have died
Vietnam like I don't know how their
health system works or like I don't know
how fast their ambulance comes and then
I started thinking about all the stuff
and I was like man was that the best
decision I was having a blast dude I got
some of this [ __ ] on in on the on the
GoPro that I recorded too but I was like
crazy man I can't live like you dude I
can't live like you I cannot live a day
in your [ __ ] shoes I can't do it man
I don't even like that on a regular
though no but it just happens sometimes
magic happens I don't think Mario's
gonna let me travel with you but you
traveled with me though a mile yeah but
if it's just me and you though it's
different cuz I get absorbed into what
other people do so remember what I
almost [ __ ] choke myself to death in
in Hawaii like that wasn't that was just
accident dude I [ __ ] was so [ __ ]
funny this fool I had his snorkel right
and he forgot that he was diving under
water and I decided to take a breath and
like it was oxygen and he drank [ __ ]
seawater he came up and then he threw up
so much all the fish came up to eat his
barf so where I was I thought I was
gonna drown cuz I was choking I couldn't
breathe and [ __ ]
Oh Mike if Shawn wasn't there with that
board I don't know what the [ __ ] I would
have done because I had to hold myself
up while I was barfing the water out of
my lungs and [ __ ] yeah but I mean that's
not daredevil [ __ ] that's just stupidity
right but like nothing will ever top you
for picking out a hooker dude that'll
never I'll have more stories that'll
give bits and pieces throughout the
years there's just things man you know
where that memory came from so like I'm
not a so I [ __ ] talk about perverted
[ __ ] and like you know like hentai and
porn and like I have this branding of a
big perv right but like yeah it's all
big [ __ ] jokes like yeah it's jokes
this is my way of actually preventing
myself from being one because I get it
out of my system I talk about it I'm not
in shame and I know people who are big
[ __ ] pervs but because they're so
quiet they don't say [ __ ] then shame
drives them to do the most craziest
thing I'm actually very [ __ ] mild
right like I've had less than a handful
of [ __ ] hooker experiences that's
right and it's all happened like before
my relationship with Jess this is all
way before yeah and I've had my
experiences and and at the end of the
day I love to connect and have a real
passionate relationship but I had to
experience it yeah some people never
experience it they don't know and then
you know they fantasize about it but for
me I like to test myself like you say
some [ __ ] you just like I'm not that
perverted like compared to other people
I've only had five hundred man I know
people that well maybe it's the gauge
right cuz there's like no people who
[ __ ] hookers still to this day they're
regular babies like hundreds yeah like I
am it's like [ __ ] smoking a cigarette
yes every weekend yeah every [ __ ]
weekend and I think because of that well
then maybe you know I don't know what my
audience is thinking but that is still a
hefty number only because it's illegal
out here but um the point is I wanted to
figure out like you know like what kind
of person am I like do I enjoy that know
I enjoy connection and in now I now I
know that that kind of stuff you know is
what I want but the point I was trying
to make is so like I'm not as
[ __ ] perverted as I sound but the
thing is a lot of these memories will
come out right and I have to talk about
it because earlier on humans in New York
you know how they have like pictures and
then they talk about like they had the
captions right yeah there's this old
[ __ ] grandma that they have on there
and she was like number one ho of the of
that era and she was talking about like
there was this Madame who was a really
dope pimp right and she says that she
used to be the number one top Madame for
a president mm-hmm I don't know of what
era but the president would have like a
Secret Service person wait at the door
and also like Herman the madam had his
favorite hooker sends her to his room
and Dobby about they'll be in there for
an hour and in the hooker says that all
this president wanted to do was [ __ ]
eat around for an hour what the [ __ ]
yeah and that reminded me of like I
don't know where that reminded me in
this conversation but that was like oh
[ __ ] I [ __ ] did that too and I
thought it was hilarious I'd have
[ __ ] to eat around for an hour
yeah but like I was just thinking like
that is the most funniest thing it's
like why would that happen
and then for me I can't even explain it
it's just an impulse like we're just in
the moment we're doing it and I'm just
like you know what I'm just gonna [ __ ]
them take a break and [ __ ] eat that
[ __ ] out and I'm like is in and
afterwards I'm like oh you know how many
dicks she'd probably had today that's so
[ __ ] funny then what like what was I
doing in the moment things happen for me
dude just I just go all out I used to
get scared I just [ __ ] [ __ ]
somebody without a condom dude that
alone was scary enough in my very
younger years I would just say condoms
mondo I should be [ __ ] riding me and
I'm like you know what well [ __ ] rip
the condom off throw it away [ __ ]
[ __ ] stick my dick back in put my
finger in her butt like a Bam Bam Bam
Bam Bam [ __ ] crazy dude I would just
do everything [ __ ] put my [ __ ]
mouth on her [ __ ] chin and [ __ ] and
start sucking away like it's what the
[ __ ]
by doing just inventing [ __ ] that's
[ __ ] flanimal [ __ ] weird dude and
to me like in the moment like I'm just
living it I'm just doing whatever the
[ __ ] I want when the thing when I
analyze it later that's this is when the
[ __ ] robot comes into play
what if rain comes in and he's like that
was really funny like why did you do
that like you spent an hour [ __ ]
sucking on her shoulder what the [ __ ]
that's not even a turn-on what the [ __ ]
is wrong with you she's like what did
you do
[ __ ] biting her [ __ ] elbow and
[ __ ] while you doggystyle her what like
what are you doing this [ __ ] why dude
dude member one time so so so so it was
like wow everyone knows the story but it
was me and Jason we're just [ __ ]
around in the bedroom and then like I
got her [ __ ] arm and and you know
like every we've just tested every
[ __ ] crease like I got I got in
between what do you call this [ __ ] like
the [ __ ] forearm and the bicep yeah I
[ __ ] stick my dick in there hit my
dick like every crease like in between
the the knee like the back of the knee
[ __ ] stuck at there stuck at
everywhere just experimented it wasn't
even a horny thing we were just
impulsive and stupid what the hell just
say let me just funny if I can put your
chin down and [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of your
neck I and I'll do stupid [ __ ] like that
dude [ __ ] funny dude yeah I just get
creative and I'm like let me see what
that's like I bet you you're gonna get
tagged in a bunch of videos like you
know I tried that chin [ __ ] thing it
was amazing and I thought she came on
her shoulder it was crazy
yo you have a [ __ ] button came on her
kneecap now brah I bet you putting her
dick in between her ear in her head
weight would even try that [ __ ] you
should have thought about oh my god the
[ __ ] find two fingers out like that
like a cigarette
two fingers out like you're holding the
cigarette come on come on [ __ ] take
your upper lip in your nose dude that's
[ __ ] yeah that just goes to show like
the
creative impulses that I have sometimes
they're dangerous sometimes they're just
completely stupid you know what you just
got to do what you got to do man
you got to do what you got to do when
you're [ __ ] to it you're horny you
don't know what goes on until after
that's why I always say the guy's
sensibility comes right after he comes
it's like after you come you're like
okay what the [ __ ] why did I do that
[ __ ] dude yeah that's so [ __ ] funny
man
yep she was like no tip just come back
again please please just come back again
okay just come back it's fine
anyways guys that wraps this that's a
good way to end this podcast what was
the question the stand-up thing right
anyways guys just to wrap it back up
there is no specific for me to be a
great stand-up comedian my personal
opinion just be honest have something to
say
work on your set and go out there and
try it out write stuff write write write
work on it and then work on your craft
over and over and over repetition is key
and anything that you do same thing goes
for stand up if somebody says that you
suck right now that means that you can
only get better and if you just end up
sucking your whole life well at least
you [ __ ] tried who care exactly shout
out the Danny Fang man yeah and pushing
it dude I mean number one Supporter man
Wow pshaw